all right we are on problem number 17 i
think my pen is too thick there you go
we were on problem 17 and i think i did
a good job of confusing you at the end
of the last video so i'm gonna to some
degree start from scratch so i've
left what i drew last time where you
know we had this graph that they did on
on problem 17 and they said that this is
the graph of y equals f of x
and they said which of the following
could be used to get the graph of
y is equal to f of x plus 2 so they want
us to graph essentially y
is equal to f of x plus 2.
and just so we don't get confused with
the y's and stuff i'm going to define a
new function called a g of x
hopefully this will not confuse you and
just simplify something and i'll call g
of x is equal to f of x plus 2. and i
did that because i didn't want two y's
here i want you to realize that this is
a different function and you know these
aren't the same function or the same y
so i'm going to define a new function
called g of x is equal to f of x plus 2.
so first let's just write a little table
and that we can understand a little bit
about f of x
so
when i had
f of x
we know a couple of things when x is
zero
f of x
is one
when x is one
right f of x is zero we know that right
so let's do another table for g of x
so
g of x
so let's do x
so now
let's let's think about it in a slightly
different almost in a reverse
way
we know we know a couple of values we
know what we know what f of 0 is right
we know f of 0
and we know f of 1.
right we're given right here we know f
of zero
is equal to
is equal to one and we know f of one is
equal to zero
now what value do i have to stick into g
of x for x to get f of zero
well i said g of x is equal to f of x
plus 2 right
g of x is equal to f of x plus 2. so to
get f of 0 i need to put a negative 2 in
here
i need to put a negative 2 in here right
g
of negative 2
is equal to f of minus 2 plus 2 which
equals f of 0
right
so this is g of minus 2
is the same thing as f of 0 and so x is
minus 2. so when x is minus 2
g of x is equal to 1 right
x is minus 2 g of minus 2 is the same
thing as f of 0 because
you get the minus 2 plus 2 and that
equals 1. so there we go g of minus 2 is
equal to 1.
then
what value do i have to give put into g
to get f of 1. so what do i have to put
here for this expression right here to
be equal to 1. well it has to equal
negative 1.
g of -1
g of negative 1
if you put negative 1 into g you get
negative 1 plus 2 which is 1. that's the
same thing as f of 1. so that equals 0.
so when x is at negative 1 g of negative
1 is 0. so let's draw g let's draw g
when x is equal to 2 i'll draw it in a
well i'll draw it in this slightly in
this color
when x is negative 2
so this is negative 2.
we have
g of x is equal to one
so this is this right here is a point
so this is at negative two zero
and then
we also have the point negative one
comma zero so we also have this point
negative one comma zero
1 comma 0
it's that point
and so what we see what happened is is
that g of x is actually a shift to the
left by 2.
and if you
if you remember so g of x is going to
look something like this it's going to
look
like the other graph just shifted to the
left
right essentially we just took the other
graph we shifted it to the left
and we we we didn't do it with all the
points we could have done it with more
points but we did it with the two points
that we know definitely are defined for
f of x right and and those two points
definitely were shifted to the left
and if you didn't you know this is
actually a little bit complicated and a
very simple way of thinking about this
problem is in general if i have f of x
then f of x
plus
anything you know f of x plus
2 in this case is going to be the same
graph of f of x except i'm shifting it
to the left and it's a little
unintuitive that i'm adding 2 but i'm
shifting to the left and the intuition
behind that is well
before f you know wherever whatever
value f of 0 was
now
that's going to happen when i put a
negative 2 in right so that's the
intuition why you're shifting to the
left the old 0 is now the new negative 2
right similarly f of
x minus 2
that shifts a graph so f of x minus 2 if
i wanted to draw that would look
something like this it would like go
like this
and it would come down and it would go
like this so that would be shifting to
the right by two
and shifting up and down is actually
much easier shifting if we have f f of x
and if we want to shift it up
say by two then we'd have f of x plus
two we would just change the y-intercept
or if we wanted to shift it down we'd
have f of x minus 2.
hopefully i didn't confuse you with all
of this jargon i mean the easy way to
think about it is really just what i
told you you know this rule but i don't
want you to just have the rule i want
you to hopefully have a little bit of
intuition on on how the shifting works
let's move on to the next problem
oh i didn't tell you which choice that
was
well if you just shift it to the left
two it looks like choice number c
all right we're at number 18
18 and they have this figure
look something just a
triangle it's like that within that
there's another triangle
looks like that
and then we have
it says
in the figure above a b is equal to b c
so a b so this big triangle
i'll i'll draw it maybe i'll draw it in
the c i'll try this color so this this
side
a b is equal to bc so that's those sides
are equal and what does that immediately
tell us if we have two angle two sides
are equal that means that the base
angles are equal that means that this
angle
is going to be equal to this angle
what else do we know
and
d e is equal to ef is equal to df so we
also know i'll switch colors that d e is
equal to ef which is equal to df
and that immediately tells us this is a
60 60 or this is an equilateral triangle
all the sides are the same so all the
angles have to be the same so this angle
has to be equal to this angle which has
to be equal to this angle and they're
all going to be 60 degrees
they're all going to be equal to 60
degrees
okay now what else are they telling us
if the measure of angle abc so abc so
this angle
is 30 degrees that's what they're
telling us
and the measure of b
of what did they say bde so b bde
is 50 degrees so this is 50 degrees
they want to know what dfa is so dfa so
we want to figure out
this angle right here
so this is the angle game again
so a couple of things if this angle up
here is 30 what are these base angles
going to be
well they're going to have to add up all
of them combined add up to 180 right so
that means that these two are going to
add up to 150 because you know 180 minus
30. and they're the same so they're the
same and they add up to
150 they're both going to have to be 75
degrees
so that's 75 degrees and that is 75
degrees right
and then what else do we know
well we know if if this angle is 50
if this angle is 60 what is this angle
right here going to be
well these three angles are going to
have to add up to 180 as well right
so 180 minus 50 is 130 minus 60
is 70. so this angle is 70 degrees
and now i could blow up you know if i
were to draw this a little bit bigger it
looks something like this
this is a this is d
this is f i'm just drawing this triangle
right here
and so this is 75
this is 70
and so what's this well 180
minus 70 minus 75 is what that's 180
minus 180
minus 145
and so that should be
degrees and that is choice b
i will see you in the next video
the important thing to realize this is
just the angle game
which i've made videos on and you just
have to keep kind of saying oh the
angles in the triangle add up to 180 or
the you know they're supplementary so
they have to 180 or you just have to
remember that if the sides are equal
then the base angles are equal and then
you can figure them out because you know
what the third angle is i'll see you in
the next video